so what's happening with the Oscars and
Halle shorts yeah well it's uh it's been
a pretty good now qualifying for three
years so is our third year coming up
that we're in Oxford qualifying festival
so what that means is our grand prize
winning film for last two years has been
automatically qualified for the Academy
Award consideration so it started three
years ago now that now that's also
kicked up this year with two out of
categories so now this year the grand
prize winning film will still be
qualified like like last few years like
always but we've also added Best Short
live action that category that winner
for our festival will also be qualified
so not only just a grand prize winner
but a short live action winner will also
be qualified in the best animation so no
animation category is also covered by
our festival so so this year coming up
2019 those three winners of those
categories will be qualified for the
Oscars so now we have more films that
have a chance to be nominated so instead
of having our grand prize winning film
that's great one film right there now we
actually have three films have a chance
to be nominated so that's very exciting
for us and of course exciting for the
filmmakers so for us more reason why the
value of the submission is there so so
you win those categories you now
qualified
now when the qualification happens then
those films are qualified now we're in
the pool at the Oscar judges in the jury
review the film's to select which films
get shortlisted and then after that
which films get qualified and actually
nominated I mean so they're nominated so
so this year we had well let me go back
two years ago Shore live-action category
at three of the five films so three of
the five films two years ago were were
nominated and the winner silent child
was art one of our films so the winning
films from Howie Schwartz two of the
other ones were from our festival as
well and our Best Director for my nephew
at MIT also nominated as well and
watching what day so that film as well
so two of those films were winners at
our festival the one that didn't win
actually at our festival won the Oscar
so it says a lot about the competition
in the quality was really cool to have
three or five for that category for
live-action last year this year we have
one film in every category so we have
short live-action with skin which is
exciting because that film skin won our
festival so it was qualified by us so we
feel sort of a very passionate about
this film we love the filmmakers love
the film the story I think it's a
fantastic film we believed it I felt
very early on when I first saw it I'm
recalling the-- i was like look you
gotta watch this right away and i felt
very strong at this
that's gonna be something I just knew I
just I don't know just felt really
strong about it just felt it had a real
chance to be something and it's cool to
see that process come through because
you believe it's something to say hey
this is I just see it you see you watch
it you feel I felt strong about it just
made me kind of jump out of my seat like
oh this is something I got a call feel
about right now we got to come because
it's gonna watch this movie we're gonna
talk about it
he watched the right away we talked we
really strongly feel great about it or
accepting in this film's gonna get in
this is one they just just put a blue
one away
so then goes with festival jury loves it
as well
unanimous and wins Best Short so it was
it was really really really well taken
by the jury which is rare to see there's
sometimes a debate and think this was
one of these films I just you know II
kind of loved and to have that
qualification happen our festival thing
one to be nominated it's very exciting
for us so we really feel good about
skins chances and they're really happy
for them to be nominated is pretty cool
and then we also have film weekend's in
animation category that also nominated
as well and that was a finalist of our
festival last year and then a
documentary lifeboat I know about the
refugee situation and it's really
amazing film and in that film also also
nominated as well so dock animation and
live-action those three categories we
have a film in each and also we have one
other dock that wasn't the festival last
year but the filmmaker is a past best
director winter so an alumni that she is
now also nominated for her documentary
period end of sentence so that film was
also nominated so it's kind of we really
have four films of all the qual the
nominated films this year which is
really neat so and then also in each
category so what if we went all three
that'd be pretty awesome if all three of
those one that would be the Grand Slam
I'll be really incredible if all those
films won Oscars I'd be really neat so
so very excited that as years of on on I
mean early years the festival we didn't
have many films that were nominated it
just wasn't you know we weren't there
yet the level of quality the the the
competition aspect the qualification
aspect that we weren't qualified so we
didn't have that going on then years
past eight nine years and year ten we
started to get more films that were
nominated and winning Oscars we were
started seeing hey these films are here
too we should be qualifying like we're
our level of quality is there on par
with the Oscar stuff so that's when we
started the process of application and
all that and now being qualified and
seeing that the film's winning like skin
having that direct relation of winning
and then going on to be actually
nominated and all that is exciting it's
like now that there's a direct effect of
seeing the the line of
the festival and going on to be nominee
is so to see that many films now and all
the categories covered it's pretty cool
so it's been a growth to see not just
one film here and there but now I have
three four or five films each year in
the pool of being nominated and some of
the winning is it's really awesome so
you know again part of that growth and
and and strengthen the festival and
seeing that you know go to court
efficient and and that happened now and
then hopefully just obviously continues
and to undergo all the films will be
from the festival that'd be pretty cool
of all nominated films will be from Olli
shorts but you know we're happy to see
that that number is going up and up
every year so it's been pretty cool to
see that that growth and not being
qualifying and seeing the films you know
the Oscars it's pretty awesome
you